comme ils sont séparés remis ensemble
séparés remis ensemble mais non c'est
pareil qu'une fois mais en ce moment il
paraît qu'il y a des rumeurs il y a
plein d'ex qui se remettent avec des
mais oui mais oui exceptionnel mais oui
arrêtez de penser parce qu'on trompe
qu'on ne peut pas se remettre avec
quelqu'un quand même non alors
25 ans de sa mort on va tout dire avec
un expert et après on aura le gros
dossier sur l'amour après 50 ans mais
pour le moment je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure effectivement on parlait de de
Britney Spears et c'est vrai qu'Elton
John c'est son ami mais c'est vraiment
son ami et il a voulu la sauver il l'a
appelé au téléphone ils sont parlé parce
que lui il a pas besoin d'un duo de plus
hein pardon il est millionnaire quand il
est venu pour être un faux à la défense
Arena à Paris il est venu en jet il est
reparti en jet parce qu'il voulait pas
dormir là et il a touché un million de
dollars pour les deux heures de show
donc globalement ça va pour lui et donc
qui fait comme il était en vacances à
Nice comme chaque année il est allé sur
l'île Sainte-Marguerite les îles Lérins
voilà il est alléchantée sa chanson
comme ça cette chanson
mais avant que je monte cette chanson je
reçois un coup de téléphone c'était le
23 je reçois un coup de téléphone en
août alors de son assistant qui
m'appelle et qui me dit je vous passe
Elton et ouais pourquoi c'est sérieux
sérieux excuse-moi est-ce que si je
m'entends je menteuse mentais je serai
animateur non alors tu peux tu te tais
tu te tais-toi c'est très court et il me
dit je suis à Nice je viens chanter je
fais un petit bœuf pour la chanson que
je fais avec Britney est-ce que ça
t'amuse de venir mais d'où il connaît
c'est ça l'histoire
tous les gens savent qu'on est potes
et je lui ai dit Elton je suis je suis à
Mykonos mais non mais si j'avais pu
j'aurais adoré et j'ai raté ça mais le
fait qu'il m'appelle quand même flatteur
il y a personne que ça surprise
par Bernard Montiel c'est pas tout à
fait est-ce que tu as des preuves est-ce
que tu as des preuves regardez il chante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]